now speaking of mojave max the assembly  tour went to stanford in the northeast  valley mr dave there the handyman about  the school he agreed to dress up as a  tortoise so the kids could learn about  the body parts and a shout out to miss  hennessy because she had a couple of  kids attending virtually and she made  sure they got to see the assembly on the  laptop computer miss noack and miss  nunez also if you want to learn about it  visit mojavemax.com kids can guess when  mojave max wakes up and they have a  chance to win a laptop computer field  trip pizza party the springs preserve  heather that is a pretty good deal all  right